what is going on guys welcome to the
second part of the live updating charts
within matplotlib I know you all are
just itching to get these charts out so
sorry I made you guys look at
documentation pretty much nobody likes
it but you can find all kinds of gems in
there so with that let's go ahead and
get started we're going to need to
import a few things from matplotlib
first we're going to want to import PI
plot so we're going to import mat plot
live pipe lot and PLT that just makes it
so we can instead of having to write all
of this out we just put plc my stuff and
pour mat plot lived on an animation as I
guess we'll just do animation we're only
going to mention this one time so it's
kind of useful to have the whole thing
right now and then finally we're gonna
import well we don't we don't totally
need it but we're gonna go ahead and
import time anyway just in case I wanted
to see the birth so next thing we want
to do is we define our figure just like
always so big equals PLT dot figure
empty parameters there you can specify
figure size and some other stuff in
there but for now let's leave it blank
then we're specify ax 1 for axes 1 for
now it's gonna be our only axes but if
you're coming from any of my other ones
you know a lot of times you might have a
lot more than just one accidents so
anyway Figg dot add underscore subplot
and in here it's gonna be a one by one
and obviously there's only one option
so it would be chart number one and that
will box there now what we need to do is
define our function here so what I'm
gonna do is define animate and within
animate we're gonna have one parameter
which is unique I now the next thing
that we want to do is we need to have
somewhere that we're getting data right
so what I did is made a sample file
called sample text and let me just bring
that up in
and here is our sample file so the it's
just a bunch of x and y's right so one
two two three three six four nine and so
on so if you don't already have one why
don't you go ahead in week one with a
right-click new makes them some sort of
text document and just put some sample
variables right on in there and then
just go ahead and leave it open because
then we're gonna we're gonna reference
this and then we're gonna edit it live
and you don't need to make it with a
notepad plus plus obviously you can make
any any text editor really so once
you've made up your sample file of X's
and Y's the next thing that we're going
to do is finish up what we were doing
and come over here and we're gonna say
pull data equals open and within here
we're going to do I called mine sample
text text so sample text text with the
intention to read it let's go ahead and
read it next we're gonna say data array
equals pull they did that split and then
let's specify X R or X written and then
why are or wiring subsequently now or
new is for each line in data array I
would just I'm gonna throw in this
little if statement here you don't have
to put this but a lot of times text
documents are going to come with like an
empty line so I just throw like a quick
stupid if statement here like if land
each line greater than one right we need
at least two variables here then we'll
do the following that way if you do have
an empty line it will will kill you so a
lot of like a lot of sources will have
empty lines just because of like the way
you append a file usually end with a new
line and so like that's why you always
end up with these extra lines but anyway
if that is the case X Y so X comma Y so
this is unpacking the thing here so it
equals each line got split by a comma so
this makes two variables the first one
will be ax
ey so then we're gonna say X R for X or
a dot append and then we need to convert
it to an integer because right now it's
a string and then we'll do the same
thing with y yr and int X and that's it
now we come over here and we want to do
is a X 1 dot Y X are Y are nothing else
we can make pretty colors and all this
stuff but we're going to do that for me
so that's our function and there's gonna
be one more thing added to that function
but first I won't do it I just want to
finish this for you guys so then we're
going to say an e for enemy equals
animation dot bump and nation pay
attention to the capitalizations here
and then here we put big animate so this
is the figure right it's corresponding
to this figure up here so that's the
figure that we're putting in there the
function we want to pass through is this
animate function and then interval
equals and we're going to make this 1000
so the interval is how often do we want
to refresh this and this is in
milliseconds so this will equal one
second so every second this will refresh
and then what we're going to do is plot
that show so we'll save that and as long
as we haven't had any errors this will
generate a graph and it will change
colors for us because of what we've done
so here's our graph and as you can see
it is changing colors on us lab just
looks so beautiful now the reason it's
changing colors is it's actually
redrawing a line over a line every
single time and what this is going to
eventually do is just brutalize your
memory so the next thing that you want
to do is just so you can see that it was
really live updating I decided to do
that but what you want to throw in here
is a X 1 dot clear empty parameters and
that will clear the plot so let's bring
that up one more time and now you see
that it looks a little bit better now
and if I was
like let's say we throw in oh I see what
I did this weird straight line
anyway why are eight on a pen you a pen
why let me close this out let's see that
one more time here
save that run it okay that's more of
what it ought to look like yeah we are
already running the clear so your line
probably looked like that because you're
probably nice silly as I am right so now
what we can do is we can bring the text
editor over here and since you don't
know that it's really live we can do ten
seven in our text editor hit save and
now you can see that the line updated so
then we do 11500 and then now you can
see it changed again so anyway those are
just the basics and a real quick example
of a live updating chart so with that
I'm gonna conclude this video as always
thanks for watching thanks for the
support subscriptions and until next
time